[Musique]
alors sur ces images du canada
en direct de montréal cet am dam canada
ça sonne très canadien cette édition
alors félicitations à notre équipe
technique aujourd'hui encore une fois on
retrouve un studio pierre luc blais marc
andré deschamps et pier dutil
grâce à ces trois rois nous allons
pouvoir accueillir aujourd'hui notre
rênes de l'émission on l'applaudît
n'applaudissent parce que je suis je
suis la seule femme en ce moment soit
dans la régie technique au studio alors
voilà on a donné le titre de reine aulas
c'est le beau drapeau qu'à passer devant
l'écran est ce que le drapeau peu
rapaces et parce qu'on n'est pas sûr
qu'on est à radio canada international
est ce que pour la ta peau peut revenir
à la self quelque chose multiples
techniques fantastiques magnifiques
oui avec le bruit oui c'est cette façon
et ses quelques euros ça vient avec un
effet sur leur marque et ça c'est mon
jeu j'aime passer comme la marche
bonjour mcmurry bonjour mais vous savez
très bien je ferai
bonjour maman m'a bienvenue une autre
belle émission marque c'est pas votre
émission c'est bienvenu quand même à
noter mission ces visites de la section
anglaise de radio canada
effectivement international faut le
préciser écoutez on a entendu à votre
émission il ya une heure un extrait d'un
débat en politicien c'était en direct à
montréal hier soir les élections
fédérales bien sûr ils étaient six sur
le plateau et vous aviez la traduction
simultanée en anglais c'était quelque
chose vous allez le faire c'était
complètement hallucinant surtout quand
il parlait les unes sur les autres et
les des traducteurs ont fait la même
chose parler de traduction sur cette
expérience était un cran
incompréhensible alors que tu aurais pas
ici parler de politique aujourd'hui on
va parler d'un autre sujet beaucoup plus
important à écouter ta politique
maintenant mais le reste même la vie
voici le sujet de l'émission aujourd'hui
vous allez devinez ensemble grâce à ses
cinq images et tout le monde à la maison
vous jouez le jeu avec nous vous avez
pas le choix si zot au bureau vous avez
le choix on peut aller marcher prendre
une marche pas voici on présente cette
vidéo 5 images
je vous promets que ça va être difficile
de déterminer de découvrir que le sujet
est bien sûr que ce sera 17 je ne sais
pas mme on attend en attaque
gst doute pour stéphane est très bon m
de bois on regarde semble premières
images
ça c'est sympathique comme image belle
couleur aide à l'international ouais ça
pourrait être ça l international
continue voyons si vous êtes bien sur la
bonne piste ou peur d'un l'aide
internationale qui accorde le canada à
l'étranger monde devrait lancer est ce
que c'est ce que cette quatrième le
photo justifie votre opinion et celle ci
québec avec les sigles américaine
alors moi je pense que c'est peut-être
haïti non c'était regarder si la seule à
l'écran aide internationale que des
photos privées certains pays parce qu'il
ya un chef en ce moment qui croit qu'il
faudrait réduire l'aide internationale
que des pays sauf que voilà cibler de
façon de faire il dit si votre indice de
pauvreté n'est pas suffisamment bas
pourquoi recevriez vous de l'argent du
canada non peu non mais il a par exemple
la chine qui a reçu d'argent du canada
litanie oui dans le cadre de tremblement
terre alors voir regarder ça ensemble
une belle occasion pour nous pour voir
bien sûr ce chef conservateur qui promet
de réduire de 25% la ligue canadienne
l'humanitaire c'est important d'en
parler mais aussi c'est une occasion
pour nous de voir où se situe le
gouvernement libéral depuis son élection
en 2015
dans cette fameuse question alors j'ai
pour vous pourquoi c'est de trouver la
racine de cette réponse
on commence par le mot action il se
produirait en studio comme d'habitude
grand plein s'il vous plaît là mais une
marque m'a battu parce qu'une dernière
sa vie a pris deux actifs
parce que bien qu'elle passa à la boule
quoi
pour flore que vous aviez votre leçon
sinon voilà obligée de la mef a sauté
les plombs grâce à ça incroyable eux
l'énergie qu'on va aller chercher la fac
sa première question la fiche à l'écran
ok on regarde ça ensemble
c'est en français malheureusement marqué
on pourrait traduire en anglais
simultanément fait s'il le faut voici
cette question voici quelle est la
contribution de l'aide internationale
canadienne comparé à nos revenus bruts 1
comparer tous nos revenus
quelle proportion quel pourcentage est
ce que l'on met de côté pour l'aide
internationale
est ce que ca 0.88 pour ça ouais est ce
que c'est vraiment pas lui c'est pâques
adressé 0,4 soit c'est ça à ce que c'est
bizarre ces rampes à 60 nitoo ouais est
ce que c'est c'est qu'entre 0 point fort
les way ou est ce que c'est des 0.3
point vous dit quoi et en anglais nous
c'est virgule moi ok bonjour porter la
même chose alors ce n'était pas
compliqué vous gardez vos 20 boules de
ce premier jeu il y a trois jeux à
l'émission mais la grosse surprise c'est
que c'est les libéraux de justin trudeau
qui ont donné dans l'ensemble moins
d'argent termes de pourcentage que le
gouvernement conservateur précédent de
stephen harper qu'il y avait été
critiqué parce qu'on disait bon il
enlève tout le soutien à l'international
tout cet intérêt du canada pour les
questions internationales il a décidé de
commercialiser la proche canadiennes de
faire en sorte que le ministère du
commerce international soient plus
impliqués dans les décisions qui
s'appelait affaires mondiales ouais
exactement ce mister s'appelle toujours
affaires mondiales gêne c'est exactement
donc le nom est resté
l'argent est un petit peu et pas au
rendez vous sous trudeau jean léger les
chiffres ici 0,28 pour ça comme vous le
disiez en anglais et puis avance sous
stephen harper 0 3% vers pour ça écoutez
je vous demande montre une petite image
comparative par pays dos et des heures
pour vous montrer une image une image ou
plusieurs bombes même en anglais s
arrête de faire des farces avec vous là
dessus voici l'aide publique au
développement en 2018
en termes de revenu national brut le
canada qui est loin à la traîne
par exemple le royaume uni l'allemagne
et derrière la france et met en avance
sur le japon nations plus riches que
nous est en avance sur les états unis
mais on va le voir un peu plus tard
c'est qu'il faut s'attendre à voir si en
terme de chiffres ou de dollars absolus
si du côté des drones à moins donner
quelques conservateurs parce qu'on sait
que les revenus bruts dans les quatre
dernières années au canada ont augmenté
tandis qu sur l'europe
on est en période de récession bah
écoutez tellement une belle question
c'est la première question pour notre
invité aujourd'hui sur skype qui est
avec nous qu'ils avaient accepté de
jouer le jeu pour nous faire comprendre
ce qui se passe du côté de
l'international canadienne françois des
de l'école des sciences de la gestion
université du québec à montréal ne sut
audet bonjour bonjour est ce que vous
voyez nous fasse patibulaire tout à fait
et la boule de lumière également c'était
impressionnant
c'est par le jeu un conte informe vous
vous êtes habitués évidemment des jeunes
les jeunes les étudiants peu
indiscipliné considérée ni comme
l'ad'ailleurs de vos classes d'accord et
pas pour écouter
bonne question de maryse dans le
contexte vous pouvez re place et ça ça
nous aiderait beaucoup essayé de
comprendre ce qui se passe
oui on fait tout ça n'est pas simple et
ça ne ça ne peut pas qu'un trisomique
par des chiffres et de là je crois la
conversation qu'on a aujourd'hui sur la
proposition des conservateurs de couper
l'aide de 25 pour ça il ya quand même un
consensus sur l'utilisation des
pourcentage du pib et des pourcentage du
pib nous permet de pouvoir comparer la
richesse collective d'un pays et sa
capacité de générosité à l'international
donc c'est sur cette base là qu'on peut
se comparer plus facilement évidemment
parce que tous les économies puis on
vous l'avait bien dit avant que j'arrive
tout les économies ne sont pas pareils
on ne vit pas des mêmes cycles
économiques au même moment non plus mais
globalement il faut qu'on regarde tous
niveaux historiques on est capable de
pouvoir
grosso modo depuis 5,10 à ou par période
comment quelle est la posture canadienne
et je crois que ce que vous avez dit
depuis le départ est bon en fait je
crois je vous ai préparé et bon c'est à
dire que le canada est un pays
moyennement généreux et je n'aime pas
mon propre terme parce que je suis pas
d'accord que le canada qui on doit
utiliser le terme généreux dans ce
contexte là je crois que le canada a une
responsabilité d'âge et sa richesse et
partage de richesses et en plus il faut
bien comprendre les points seulement au
bénéfice des pays qui reçoivent cette
aide là mais au bénéfice du canada s'est
aussi souvent le narratif libéral qui
dit bah quand vous donnez de l'inde un
pays y ait 10 et dépôts stables belle
amélioration de sa stabilité va
permettre aux canadiens d'avoir une
meilleure une meilleure posture et
d'être plus plus organisés d'avoir de
meilleures opportunités si vous voulez
donc grosso modo et je résume à penser
en quelques secondes sous les sous en
fait depuis vingt et un ans l'aide
canadienne est plus ou moins la même
temps on peut même se reporter à
l'époque de jean chrétien
les conservateurs avaient modifié
certaines approches mais avait maintenu
un peu quand même l'inde en termes de
pourcentage et sous les libéraux on
avait on avait porté le libellé de la
politique des féministes mais y'avait
pas de nouvelles sommes qui sont arrivés
malgré une économie croissante
on était quand même on était dans une
approche le conomique positive et c'est
ce qui fait en sorte effectivement que
le pourcentage lui diminuer la récente
récente administration libéral
professeur odéon vient de montrer des
images on va leur montrer à l'instant de
la ministre responsable de ce dossier la
ministre du développement international
marie claude bibeau qui étaient avec
nous lors d'une entrevue il ya une
couple d'années où on parlait de la
féminisation de l'aide internationale
canadienne
on se disant la tête moins d'argent
mater on va agir de façon plus
intelligente au niveau des sommes bon ça
se discute il peut y avoir des débats il
ya aussi la façon dont on intervient
comme pays et un douche il parle
d'intervenir d'une autre façon parlons
de celle que qu'a voulu privilégier
jusqu'à maintenant les libéraux puis
marie une question par rapport
oui parce que tu as well moody's étudier
le mot généreux est-ce qu'on devrait
parler de parcimonie mais choisis selon
les politiques du gouvernement au
pouvoir de toucher l'aide internationale
déjà l'aide au même le mot aider pour
moi il est un peu maladroit c'est
souvent je pense que l'international
parce qu'on garde quand même les termes
ont toujours été à la couleur du
ministre ou de la ministre responsable
ou du parti responsable
l'aide est toujours intéressé est
politisé et quand on commence à regarder
en détail les projets les pays qui
reçoivent de l'aide canadienne
ben on peut jamais trouvé une raison
essentiellement humanitaire ou
essentiellement altruiste il ya toujours
des intérêts commerciaux
il ya toujours des intérêts politiques
des diasporas il ya toujours des
pressions des alliés il ya toujours une
raison politique qui va faire que le
canada va ou ne va pas donner de l'aide
pays tiers premièrement pour en revenir
à la question sur ce que les libéraux
ont fait avec notamment la politique
d'être féministe
ces dernières années je crois que c'est
un choix juste judicieux
c'était une politique qui était
féministe donc le libellé entente elle
était même extrêmement ou très moderne
progressif pas tarder une perspective
canadienne parce que pour lui et quand
même certains acquis mais quand on aime
on met en place des politiques là
notamment pour des pays pour qui dans
lesquelles les enjeux de quelqu'un de
femmes sont sans trop avoir même
évidemment il ya des violations
quotidiennes de la réalité des femmes et
aussi parce qu'on sait c'est bien
documenté scientifiquement que le
développement humain passe par les
femmes donc de libérer la politique
féministe est extrêmement importante par
contre si on lui donne pas de coercitif
si on ne donne pas de moyens financiers
financiers ça devient se marquent une
politique et qu'un discours narratif et
c'est malheureusement beaucoup ce qui
est arrivé dans les dernières années
donc ai pas beaucoup d'argent
maintenant c'est un peu mieux ça que ça
a pris du temps avant que les projets
s'enracine dans la politique des
féministes
mais pendant que les premières années on
était beaucoup plus dans un art hâtif et
ça n'a pas changé grand chose en commun
mais là maintenant avec les années la
plupart des projets ont des obligations
de s'assurer qu'une analyse de genre et
de s'assurer que les femmes soient non
seulement considérer mais les moteurs du
développement humain derrière les
projets mais juste une question est-ce
que c'est peut-être un peu simpliste de
dire le canada dan x dollars à l'italie
ou aux chinois quelque chose parce qu'on
ne donne pas d'argent au gouvernement
directement me sens mais plutôt aux
organismes humanitaires dans ces pays
donc c'est pas exactement le même genre
de discussions me sens vous avez tout à
fait raison et c'est fondamental que
vous posiez la question parce que l'aide
canadienne est rarement ou pas souvent
attribués au gouvernement
elle est parfois et quand les bases cd
et cd cd entendre qu'on aperçoit
bilatérales et là ce sont des pays très
qui répondent à des indicateurs de bonne
gouvernance qui répondent à des preuves
à des programmes très très bien encadré
dans le cas qui nous a interpellés ces
dernières semaines avec l'annoncent où
la proposition tu comptes du parti
conservateur
c'était effectivement je crois une focus
m'en informer la population que le
canada à donner de l'aide à l'italie le
canada a donné de l'argent à des
organisations notamment à la croix rouge
pourrait d une région d'italie qui
étaient sous les décombres
et on peut espérer que si une situation
similaire survenu au canada afin que les
italiens ou d'autres pays peu importe
qu'ils sont vrais nous aider c'est le
propre de l'aide
même chose pour certains pays qu'on
considère un peu plus riches notamment
le liban ou la jordanie
ce n'est pas la jordanie qui reçoit ces
sommes là c'est des organisations
humanitaires les nations unies parfois
les ong ou la croix rouge pour aider les
réfugiés
qui arrivent dans les pays qui eux sont
extrêmement généreux on parle au liban
je crois que c'est plus de 50% de la
population ce sont des réfugiés alors le
canada donc valant qu'octroyer des
sommes à des organisations qui vont
gérer aider les populations réfugiées
mais c'est sûr qu'après dans le cahier
du dit statistique canada ballon dit le
canada a envoyé cet argent dans un pays
qui s'appelle la jordanie mais c'est pas
le pc pas le les coffres il le budget de
la jordanie qui ont reçu cet argent à
leur est pas du tout évidemment
revenons à un dieu chiffres dont on
vient elle de voir des images alors
qu'il était en campagne électorale il a
promis une réduction de 25% est il assez
sa tournure et il a dit on va sauver de
l'argent pour payer des choses aux
canadiens j'ai pas sûr que il devait y
avoir cette juste juste à position entre
ne pas donner pour mieux recevoir c'est
un petit peu l avais je sais pas et
j'entends un message un peu 30 rompiez
ada vous desservir nous mêmes avant de
servir les autres
un peu ça ouais est-ce qu'ils étaient
obligés d'aller à la en termes 2 de son
électorat en tête des gens qui sont
prêts à voter pour son parti ou qui
pourrait changer à voter pour le parti
conservateur
ce kit de l'aller jusque là bas est
petit personnellement je vais évidemment
avoir une posture aux plus critiques par
rapport à ce genre de propositions
politiques là le canada n'est pas
généreux et fait partie des on est dans
quoi 14/15 pays donateurs de lots cdr
donc des pays de l'occident
ici on devait diminuer notre aide pour
nos propres besoins
on sera encore moins généreux donc on
donnera com - nous ressources minimum de
notation selon lui les pourcentages tout
à l'heure c'est pas beaucoup d'argent
donc la proposition des conservateurs se
fait sur cette base là à dire qu'on va
garder l'argent parce que nous on a des
besoins
c'est un discours de politique
domestique à ce moment là c'est fort
probablement et le jeu il faudrait avoir
un autre expert kanda du politique
canadienne et si vous voulez mon avis ma
compréhension c'est que le gouvernement
conservateur a des priorités politiques
il ya besoin d'aller chercher des sous
dans le budget et il voit danser dans ce
budget international a pas d'intérêt
pour son aîné
[ __ ] art évidemment il va dire on veut
couper quelques milliards d'aed à
l'international pour financer nos
propres besoins
populisme à la trompe c'est une très
bonne question et là on pourra laisser
le temps monsieur scheer de mieux faire
connaître pour voir si on en est là je
vous dirais que je ne sais pas si c'est
du populisme
par contre c'est en fait un jeu de mots
c'est un peu trompeur effectivement
parce que ce n'est pas c'est une très
mauvaise compréhension des
interconnexions de la mondialisation que
de croire que de ne pas partager une
partie de notre richesse à certains pays
n'a pas de bénéfice pour nous et on l'a
vu ces dernières heures ces derniers
jours quand le gouvernement américain a
décidé de retirer ses troupes de la
syrie le lendemain qu est ce qui est
arrivé
la turquie a attaqué le menthe et je
vous dis pas qu'il faut maintenir des
troupes militaires vitam aeternam dans
un pays par contre le fait de jouer ou
de défaire ou de faire des noeuds à
l'international ont des conséquences
directes sur la sécurité mondiale sur la
sécurité régionale sur l'économie
mondiale et éventuellement sur la
pression migratoire les demandes de
réfugiés
les gens qui cogne à nos frontières et l
économie mondiale dans lesquels nos
compagnies nos entreprises et notre
budget est interrelié donc tout ça est
interconnecté c'est pas aussi simple que
de dire on va prendre un milliard ou 2
par là et on va le mettre dans nos
infrastructures et ça ça changera rien
c'est absolument progrès et le message
qu'on envoie en plus c'est que le canada
se désintéresse se retire de la scène
internationale et que feront nos alliés
à ce moment là même probablement le
seront aussi
et oui sa rentrée dans un mode de
populisme dans une analyse du populiste
voudrait qu'on est certainement dans une
dans une perspective protectionnistes
replier sur nous-mêmes et clairement pas
au diapason avec ce qui se passe dans le
monde dans lesquels aujourd'hui hier
entre 20 et 22 millions de populations
qui migrent actuelle même et son retire
l'aide qu'ils sont en migration où se
sont réfugiés
ils sont retirés aux led ces populations
là vont trouver d'autres moyens pour
survivre éventuellement vous frappez à
nos frontières
donc c'est très maladroit et c'est une
politique électoraliste du d'études et
et non pas une politique dans lesquels
le canada voit qu'il ya des enjeux qui
dépassent les simples nids-de-poule dans
les centre-ville de montréal
très bien alors je vous demanderai pas
votre opinion problème je crois que
c'est clair monsieur adam merci beaucoup
de nous avoir amené vers une analyse un
petit peu plus nuancée de ce qu'on
appelle l'aide internationale ça m'a
fait plaisir et c'est une bonne émission
et bonne suite
merci beaucoup merci mais ça va françois
audet sympathique professeur qu'on
aurait aimé avoir à l'université à la
place que ce qu'on a eu alors de l'école
des sciences de la gestion
on a eu des très bons il est à lui
restait du québec à montréal pour les
gens qui seraient intéressés a suivi à
l'uqam
ben oui c'est juste à côté ce pas loin
de 6 oui moi j'aurais eu des bambous
vous avez vu des bons aussi moi je moi
je me suis un prof de chimie
monsieur gravel il rentrait d'un court
il c'était un personnage il expliqué et
on comprenait et c'est ce qui a fait que
moi j'ai fait un bac en sciences en
premier au logis parce qu'il m'a fait
aimer la science est un autre professeur
à l'université lui donner des cours de
gym où il avait étudié om haïti au
massachusetts est lui aussi mais ils
faisaient des des examens où il fallait
pas seulement cocher une case fallait
expliquer notre réponse et moi c'est ce
que j'aimais tout côté d'apprendre et de
montrer qu'on a compris quelque chose et
puis marc vous au bébé bien sûr il ya
quelques heures qui sont magnifiques il
y en a d'autres qui sont des pans de
leur investissement dans le sujet dans
la classe de leur paie toujours et il
faut admettre qu'il ya toujours des
étudiants qui sont plus d'amis que
d'autres fait normal
c'est cette drôle de voir qu'ils se
soient un regard de la classe ici ce
qu'ils s'assoient en avant est ce que
vous vous souvenez des classes où il y
avait deux ou trois cents personnes
moi g us à laval alors quand on était
derrière le professeur était pas très
gros et puis à des fouilles avaient une
projection sur un grand écran
j'ai passé encore comme ça aujourd'hui
que vous revenez d'une famille qui était
pas ouvre évidemment meilleur 3 300
étudiants dans une classe oui parce que
moment donné il y avait des cours
obligatoires de sciences entend ça et là
les gens qui viennent de différents
concentration ça se voyait dans la
classe alors là si des gens n'est pas
intéressé par la matière on va pas
coûter grand chose
y à l'époque il y avait pas les
cellulaires imaginer aujourd'hui les
trois quarts de la clastre avec les
cellulaires ne quitterait pas le
professeur des moyens de s'évader
fantastique alors on essaie d'aller
ensemble on continue à jouer ensemble on
continue à s'investir dans cette
conscience qu'en actions électricité
marche encore alors c'est notre deuxième
tour on perd combien de boules en
principe si on répond incorrectement est
la deuxième femme samse 36 30 exactement
si bien appris ma leçon
vous avez encore vos 20 boules initial
voici trente mètres au bol ça oui est-ce
qu'on passe à vous aimer dire ça non
aussi haut que je devrais pas répond à
ça on roll on roll on roll soit le
canada clark est découragé je vous
donnais une information vous avez été
passé à 34 milliards de dollars
américains en 2018 c'est ce que les
états unis ont dépensé pour
l'international
ça correspond seulement à 0 0 dans cette
comparaison 0,28 du canada
on est plus généreux en terme de notre
grosse heure et 48 minutes explique qu
est ainsi de la nuit commence à voir des
problèmes donc bien ils ont un manque
d'argent ils sont quand déficit
la suze unis sont dans un état critique
je sais qu'il ya deux personnes qui sont
donateurs en ukraine qui pourrait peut
être aider le
nations unies au niveau du financement
petit peu d'argent
vous pensez 340 mille dollars doit pas
entendu parler maintenant notre histoire
suivant les nouvelles bien sûr voici la
question s'il vous plaît deuxième
question le canada se classe auquel rang
des pays donateurs donne internationale
on se classent uni auquel rang alors
attention tous il a dit quelque chose
mais ce n'était pas tout à fait la bonne
réponse aux accords je vous dis ça tout
de suite
qu'est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on se classe
au huitième rang 10e rang 13e rang ou
18e rang moi j'ai obtenu puisque j'avais
aussi entendu c'est bon j'obtenais
disant que ce n'était pas tout à fait
vrai mais opter pour le s'est glissé
alors d'un accord commun parce qu'il me
semble que j'ai vu passer l'info pour
cette femme même 13 pour sa 13ème très
bien vous diriez 13e d'accord 10e 10
l'équipe technique qui évidemment sur
place tout le monde parce qu'ils ont la
réponse
enfin paraître alors l'impact les
angolaises en disant google est
organisée avec le gars des vues comme au
québec alors la seule réponse 10e ça va
les techniciens si vous avez la réponse
qu'on la voit à l'écran on a besoin de
se faire ça bien ouais c'est ça mais là
on parlait d'un terme 2 milliards total
d'argent
carole pour sainté pourcentage donc tout
cas bienvenue le 6 milliards de dollars
américains d'ici là la réponse le
service technique conserve toutes ces
foules en contre nous et puis qui a
personne ici qui a conservé ses boules
alors qu'on tombe on tombe à soixante
dix les deux parce qu'on en a perdu 30
et on à la baisse un bon d'accord vous
aurez été bonne en mathématiques
maintenant égale galles on va faire
apparaître pour ceux qui s'intéressent à
cette question de l'aide internationale
différents reportages qui accompagne la
diffusion de tam-tam aujourd'hui sur
notre page web
on a affiché ses cinq reportages qui a
des besoins de lunettes pour voir loin
ici qu'il est le champion de l'oeil
la bâtisse où la famille semi assise
opération pour mieux voir de loin
alors on va faire apparaître ça si vous
voyez
aider à lire les titres au moins des
titres le reste nous internautes
pourront faire le travail
on a un peu coupé le côté là l
international privé les moins pauvres
dépôts et redonne au canada c'est la
position des conservateurs on ne va pas
et le canada affirment de retour est de
retour mais les chiffres indiquent une
vérité alternative monsieur trompe et
ottawa se démarque par son leadership
un autre artiste qu'on a écrit à radio
canada international et l'aide
internationale canadienne au pouvoir des
femmes mais sans le pouvoir de l'argent
conclusion plutôt ennuyeuse ennuyeuse
parce que si on n'a pas le renvoi pas
jusqu'au bout de ces de ses discours
politique des fois il n'y a pas de
commentaire de ma part c'est simplement
une observation qui est basée sur la
réalité alternative personnes arrivent
thèmes abandonnée ce serait l'ancien
ministre qui détenait les cordons de la
bourse
au québec monique jérôme forget qui elle
avait une formation de sociologue et que
ça va être très bien négocié avec les
différents ministres qui se présente mal
pour avoir de l'argent et elle alors on
l'appelait la madame à la bourse à la
sacoche et la sacoche l'argent qui avait
dedans c'est pas n'importe qui qui
l'avait on sait qui c'est important
d'avoir deux versements main la sacoche
on comprend poursuit on pense à vous
cours des choses qui n'ont dit dans
cette émission bien sis à s'extraire
nous ont d'ailleurs pas l'attraper dit
mais vous et durée totale est beaucoup
plus important alors écoutez pour ce qui
est de l'aide internationale
le grand max ul libéral a souvent dit on
va faire ça on va augmenter parce qu'on
est à la recherche de quoi maryse on
veut faire des pressions pour obtenir
quelque chose quelque part le siège
ouais à l'onu en quelle année séjour
permanent
ces housses les bonnes questions et je
sais que monsieur christelle à cette
semaine avec un autre personnage
politique très important du canada pour
faire des pressions
on aimerait savoir ça pour 21 22 sièges
non permanents
aussi j'ai une petite question de
politique internationale géopolitique
internationale c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux c'est facile vous allez voir
vous allez garder vos 50 boules pour le
3d un troisième derniers jeux moi je le
faire dès que des heureux aujourd'hui
l'émission évidemment le service
technique qui s'y connaît la réponse
donc on ne questionne pas voici la
question troisième jeu on regarde ça
ensemble
cinq puissances détiennent un siège
permanent au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu je pas 17 mai 5
lequel de ces pays n'y figure pas est-ce
à royaume-uni b france c'est allemagne
et des chine allemagne allemagne vous
pensez vous 1 c'est très bonne question
j'hésite
les leaders de l'europe à devait faire
erreur alors est ce que ces équipes a
pas un siège au conseil permanent
sécurité de sécurité voilà croit mme uni
france allemagne chine et pourquoi audit
allemand pourquoi demandez lui paul oui
bon ben je me rallie comme ça si on
coule on coule 1,5
[Rires]
eh bien vous avez tous les deux les
commerçants et les deux tard vous avez
tous les deux raison
êtes vous prêt pour la question mais
c'est pourquoi diable voilà pourquoi je
ne sais pas pourquoi pas ce qu'est
l'allemagne a perdu la guerre avait
juste un historien seule marque senior c
d'historiens des services à radio canada
international poser une question qui a
trait à s'est passé pendant la guerre
la réponse c'est spécial mais l'ida et
l'église un couple de reprises à notre
démission et tous les musiciens ont le
feu coulée s'est soudain ma jument du
plaisir comme un tout petit mon regard
notre émission dure 11 novembre dernier
à regarder absolument non
alors moi j'ai la réponse juste part ou
par non vous connaissez je sais l'image
de la sema way that boy ne sera pas le
prochain quartier peut-être je sais pas
quelle est l'image de la semaine n 10 je
répond par oui ou par non mr mino raiola
qui ne donne pas des bonbons jacques
cartier extentions oui c'est ça c'est ça
non mais faut que je vous raconte c'est
que ce matin j'étais sur le pont
jacques-cartier et là je me suis dit est
ce que je t'ai phare dans la question de
la semaine va poser cette question là
alors je me suis dit faut garder en tête
vous êtes dans ma tête tout le temps la
très bonne note
sur cette image là il n'y a que toi
personne d'extinction le bal hier les
autres sur le pont sondé déjà qu'elle
savait dès leur descente doit cesser
c'est à dire que les aider à dix ans ça
se passe à l'heure de pointe montréal
mardi ou mercredi matin dit beaucoup de
gens qui sont jamais rendus au travail
d'autres sont arrivés en retard comme
pas pu faire leur travail c'est ce qui
m'a étonné la jeune femme qu'on a vu
avec sanquer les fans qui parlait du
haut du pont ressembler à l'ancien
député libéral chez la cote
les visages ont même âge c'est la même
et elle avait l'air très calme elle
parlait c'était vraiment très
intéressant est ce que vous pouvez
quelqu'un peut me dire qui qui d'où
vient ce groupe c'est un groupe
international moi c'est la production
stable et alors ils font des coups
d'éclat comme ça avez vous vu je pensais
yahoo ce matin il y en a un qui a
empêché un navire décoller il s'était
attaché au dessus de données d'un avion
c'est quelque chose mais il y avait
quelqu'un qui les critiquaient ce matin
dans le devoir qui disait ce serait bien
qu'ils aillent en chine ou dans des pays
où c'est plus dur et faire le même geste
pour voir si on va les traiter de la
même façon je n'accepte pas des
critiques envers la chine à cette
émission
vous le dit enfin ces deux cultures
bloquaient aussi des ponts et des
chemins toronto et vancouver victoria
cette semaine cette semaine marianne
sydney en australie
lalonde surtout parce que ça commençait
à londres en angleterre c'était mondiale
dans ce sens l'environnement est mondial
maintenant et ce depuis les pieux c'est
plus long mais sont critiqués par
exemple se disent même vous empêcher les
gens d'aller travailler ou les frustre
plus que attirer ceux souhaités c'est ça
c'est un problème assez de simplement
manifesté en et dérangera personne
marquait déjà qu'ils disent est ce qu'on
doit encore dans la manifestation
mais comment on passe à l'action
repousse toujours la personne avec qui
on dispose et d'engager les à l'ag une
très bonne suggestion vous demandez un
patron votre patron mais un patron de
vous laisser travailler à la maison
comme ça j'avais besoin de déplacer ce
serait je pense que ça fonctionnerait
pas non mais je crois que ça ou demander
une augmentation de salaire moi je
choisis un environnement je ferai un
sacrifice d'aller rester à la maison par
l'entrée dans l'auto traverser cette
année cette année l'environnement et moi
c'est comme ça écoutez c'est le vendre
existe toujours un plaisir de se
retrouver comme ça en famille parce que
c'est ça qu'on est une famille à travers
cher son frère d'un ami sur des sections
ça fait longtemps qu'on se connaît tous
connectés pour être le fasse ça pour ça
qu'il lui a fallu savait qu'il va pas le
faire les choses n'ont dit maryse merci
beaucoup c'est même lignée dans un cas
la semaine prochaine peut-être aubaine
pour vers n'ai pas fait un bon album ça
m'agace
havas
boule magique
[Musique]